[Music]
enemies to these enemies to the west
enemies to the south and the Moose to
the north whatever stands in our way we
will defeat it with a mallet
the Great Wall is he happy gameofthrones
day everyone so a lot of eagle-eyed
people have started to notice bids from
the trailer that foreshadow things in
the way the Game of Thrones loves to
foreshadow
in Dan and Dave are certainly very
careful about the way they present
information so now the new detail that
everyone is talking about is this map
theory with Cersei and Jaime that ties
into the valonqar so let's a new round
of the giveaway starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video it's for the
enhanced editions of the books but you
notice as they play the trailer Cersei
walks into the map room that she's
constructing inside the red keep that's
made to look a little bit like the
painted table that Daenerys has a dragon
stone so that she can start plotting out
her strategy it's not quite done yet you
can see little pieces of other maps that
they're using to fill in gaps that they
haven't finished yet but as she's
talking about their plan of attack
enemies to the west of us enemies to the
south enemies to the north enemies to
the east Jamie is standing here on the
portion of the map that represents the
fingers of Westeros the place where
Littlefinger is from Cersei is standing
in the neck so Maggie the frogs valonqar
prophecy that the TV show cut out of
season 5 episode 1 reads will the King
and I have children she says oh I six
and ten for him and three for youth
referencing robbers bastard separately
from Cersei and Jaime's three children
we'll talk about Gendron a little bit
too because I believe that he's coming
back around Gold shall be their crowns
and gold shall be their shroud she said
and when your tears have drowned you the
valonqar shall wrap his hands around
your pale white throat and choke the
life from you you remember Dan and Dave
borrow a lot of foreshadowing from
George our Martin in the books go back
to Jon Snow's death at the end of season
5 but way back in season 3 when
Melisandre was meeting with the
Brotherhood and Thoros she finds out
about beric Dondarrion being brought
back by the red god how many times has
the Lord of Light brought him back six
times one of the biggest examples of
doradora Martin foreshadowing a big
phenomenon that will be coming later
with Lady Stoneheart and then with Jon
Snow obviously that the winds of winter
thing in the books the TV show beat that
there that's going to be happening again
with season 7 season 8 just because
they're blowing through plot so fast in
the idea that even though events don't
outright repeat themselves exactly the
way they happened in the past a lot of
historical events like Aegon's conquest
and form a lot of the plot and
present-day Daenerys is storyline is
mirroring Aegon's conquest
Jamie's arc is seem like it's pushed him
in a more heroic direction over the
course of the series in Cersei in a more
cruel direction even if you go back to
season 1 when they were caught by bran
in the tower Jaime was quick to push him
out Cersei did not want to do that now
it seems like Jaime is the more
sympathetic of the two Cersei is the
more cruel as in Cersei the cruel maegor
the cruel you look at the brand
flashbacks and you see him kill the Mad
King you think about the story that he
told to Brienne during season 3 a very
rational reason why he said he had to do
it the Mad King was getting ready to
blow up all of King's Landing all the
women all the children just to keep
Robert and his forces from taking it he
arrives back at King's Landing and
witnesses the depths to which Cersei
will go he might not know everything
that she's done he might not know about
set to Anela but I feel like the great
set blowing up with wildfire is enough
to remind him exactly of what happened
with Aerys Targaryen so you watch him
here at the end of season 6 and then you
see him in the trailer and he seems like
he's growing more and more uneasy with
her and even though there's a long way
to go before Jaime would ever consider
killing his sister it just sounds like
they're pushing him more and more
towards that Balon Carr prophecy in the
reason why the show cut it out is
because they don't want to Telegraph
that too much but Balon car means little
brother Jaime was born right after
Cersei even though they're twins he is
the younger of the two by a couple
minutes
you also probably noticed that he's
wearing widow's wail in the trailer and
in these promo photos there's a couple
good reasons why he probably has that on
him that I explained in the last video
that I posted in the short term is
probably for more practical reasons if
you're going to be fighting a lot of
battles you want a Valyrian sword the
sword itself was sent back to Casterly
Rock by Tywin Lannister after Joffrey's
death to just wait for Tommen until he
was old enough to wield it now that
Tommen is
that Jamie is the head of House
Lannister so it makes sense that the
sword would pass to him even though the
blade isn't quite as big as Oathkeeper
or even Longclaw like Jon Snow wields
it's still way better than a normal
steel sword there's also a lot of
ceremony to wearing it to Jamie's going
to be standing at the head of the
Lannister army that's going to be a very
big deal this season the long term it
also has a lot of thematic connections
with Cersei in Jaime's history Joffrey's
death widow's wail is the name of the
sword Cersei is the widow she's been
wailing for the last couple of seasons
watching her children die what better
sword to anoint Jaime the Queen Slayer
than the sword that was given to her
dead son it was reforged from Ned
Stark's great sword eyes after the
Lannister betrayal after Joffrey went
back on his word and had him beheaded
even after he said that he wouldn't fail
a debt to the Starks and Lannister's
always pay their debts
I know Arya has all the skills of a
faceless person now and that certainly
takes away from her being able to kill
Queen Cersei but if you look at the
nurses vision here you think that
because snow is falling and King's
Landing is in ruins it implies that
winter has come because it seems like
the progression of Daenerys as visions
lead her beyond the wall like she's
getting ready to see the night king
coming before she walks into the tent
and sees her baby ray go
but this damage could have been caused
by Cersei blowing up King's Landing with
wildfire herself so you have to imagine
that a little bit of Brienne has been
rubbing off on Jaime season 2 season he
slowly been growing more honourable but
because the way the TV show has been
cutting out book plots TV show Jaime has
been much more loyal to her than book
Jaime ever was the last time she and
Jaime work together as man and woman was
over Joffrey's dead body in the books
after that he swears off Cersei so you
get a much better idea for how Jaime
feels about Cersei in the books than you
do on the TV show I think the reason
they're trying to play it a little more
vague is because of the death of
Myrcella
they want to make it feel like Jaime
wants some revenge for that but he's
still slowly coming around to the idea
that maybe Cersei is going to cross the
line maybe she's going to do the exact
same thing that Aerys Targaryen did and
try and blow up everyone in King's
Landing let me know in the comments
though what do you think about the map
theory
and do you think that it's just another
example of Danone date foreshadowing a
big twist on the TV show I think a
really good example that too is them in
this interview way way back in the early
seasons wearing this R plus l equals
polo jersey this was years years before
they made the reveal under the Tower of
joy the Jon Snow's mother with Leon a
star even though book readers have had
that theory ever since the first book
came out in the 90s after Ned Stark
starts thinking about the Tower of joy
wouldn't it be crazy if Jon Snow's
mother was Ned Stark's sister and the
pool of blood she found him in was after
she gave birth to the baby
the actress Lena Headey does have a
contract through season 8 of the TV show
but that doesn't guarantee that she's
going to be in every single episode of
season 8 there will be six episodes in
the final season they just confirmed
that so it is possible that they push a
lot of these micro Wars that are going
to be happening over the course of
season 8 through the end of the season
into early season 8 Cersei survives
until then and then finally Jamie
completes the deed because Cersei is
definitely high on my list of people
that I don't think are going to make it
to the very end of this story but she's
not incredibly high on my season 7 death
predictions list but let me know if
Cersei is going to be killed by Jaime do
you think that it's going to happen at
the end of season 7 or do you think
they'll push that into season 8 a lot of
you requested videos about Sir Jorah
what's going on with him the greyscale
what's going on with the Hound the
Brotherhood with Arya so those will be
some of my next bonus videos I'll try to
get those out as fast as possible
now that we're getting closer I'll start
posting more Game of Thrones videos per
week so leave all your requests in the
comments below congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner the Mersey is
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video I'll just name the winner the
next time I post a game of Thrones video
where you wait for that you can click
here to watch the full trailer again and
you can click here for my house dark
video thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you